as the UK is on the verge of finding out
which is the three shortlisted proposals
for airport expansion the Davis
Commission will recommend Heathrow hub
one of those proposals has asked us to
look into the subject and the ideas
behind each simon calder is travel
editor of the independent I asked him
why the UK needs more airport capacity
if you look at the way that London has
become almost by accident the world
capital of aviation you think this is
totally at odds with everything we've
been told by the aviation industry for
years decades probably but this year
London is actually increasing its lead
over the next big city in terms of
aviation something like 150 million
people will fly in and out of London's
airports in 2015 which will extend its
lead over New York which is the closest
and sure you've got the Gulf airports
coming up quickly dubai in particular
already handles more international
passengers than Heathrow but my goodness
London performs extraordinarily well and
that is why we are being told for
example that Heathrow is completely full
Gatwick is full at all the times that
anybody wants to fly there and while
stansted and Luton have a bit of space
even London cities creaking at the seams
so now we know why we need it let's have
a look at one of the options Heathrow
and why it might be a good place for an
extra runway well because we're the only
airport today in the UK these actually
full all day every day so the demand is
here for four new flight to operate also
Heathrow is the UK's only hub airport
and that's a very special status that
the airport's that only a select a
number of airports around the world have
there's only six airports around the
world that have more than 50 long-haul
destinations here at Heathrow we have 18
and the reason why we're able to operate
those long-haul destinations is because
we we combine transfer traffic so people
fly in to the airport on short-haul
flights with the demands of the
people and businesses living around
around London around Heathrow and by
combining the local demand with those
transfer passengers means that we are
able to offer more destinations more
frequencies with more airlines than any
other Airport in the UK but not everyone
is in favor of expansion especially when
we are currently trying to reduce the
deficit well it seems to me it's just
not in the interest of people not
interest of travelers not interested the
economy and not interest of the
environment to have a third runway at
heathrow when it comes to the economy
we've got this massive deficit if the
government decides to build a third
runway at heathrow there's another 20
billion pounds to spending doesn't make
any sense when if you're going to have a
short-term solution an extra wrong way
somewhere get with makes complete sense
doesn't cost the taxpayer any money but
what's more into C's competition so
Gatwick is Adam a free A's choice of the
three we spoke to charles curve and
Taylor corporate affairs and
sustainability director and Gatwick
about their proposal our case rests on
competition which is something that
we've been doing for the last five years
we've been competing heavily during that
time we've improved service we've
lowered costs and we've increased
innovation around the airport that's a
good thing for the nation as a whole the
second point is that our scheme costs
much less than that of Heathrow so in
terms of value for money which will be
ultimately paid for by the passengers we
represent a much lower cost option it's
much lower costs for the passengers and
it's much lower costs for the taxpayer
so we won't be asking the taxpayer for
any money at all the third option is
again at Heathrow but this proposal is
quite different jacques lowe director of
Heathrow hub explains
the politicians after the last election
said well no third runway and no new
people in the noise envelope so the
answer is very simple you simply make a
longer runway cut it in two and then
you've got exactly the same capacity as
if you had a neuron so all we're going
to planning to do I was suggesting is
that we extend the northern runway which
is already 4,000 meters long I'm not
needed by modern airplanes extended to
six and a half six thousand seven
hundred meters put a big safety gap in
the middle and we'll hand at one end and
take off it Billy what about the other
Heathrow expansion ideas the answer I
think has to be Heathrow we just think
our plan is easier simpler and quicker
than he throws plan and it will be a lot
cheaper but 56 billion pound cheaper I
supposed to disappointed off being so
close to the center of London is that he
throws also surrounded by how they're
surrounded by communities who are
already very annoyed about the noise of
the existing airports very easy to make
a judgment about noise in 10 15 20 years
time based on today's noise but it won't
be the same for two reasons one is it
the aircraft's becoming quieter and will
become quite as still each generation
has been quieter and secondly they've
got advanced navigation equipment which
can be used to put the airplane
approaches over very own places so you
don't always have the constant drone
until you're very close to the airport
and you can go over areas which are less
populated so we've had quite a pleasant
reception I will be done before it
doesn't mean that everyone has been
there convinced some of them still and
will continue to oppose any expansion of
Heathrow our gatwick or indeed probably
anywhere else but if you look at the
business case of what if benefit of
expanding Heathrow would have on the UK
economy it's not just west london it's
the whole of the UK
so so Howard Davis has a lot to consider
and an important decision to make a
decision we may not have to wait long to
hear